it's halloween time and call of duty is
getting into the spirit of things with
the new haunting of verdansk event
here are all the horrific details you
need to know about all the special stuff
coming to warzone and modern warfare
multiplayer
the event is called the haunting of
verdansk and
well the map is haunted thanks to the
new nighttime look you might see ghosts
on the train track
creepy dummies on the tv sets and more
matter of fact you can dress up and
scare other war zone players yourself
with some new bundles
the saw bundle lets you dress up as
jigsaw's creepy doll billy
and it comes with some special gear and
blueprints too also available is the
texas chainsaw massacre bundle
which gets you a leather face skin plus
more gear and blueprints
other bundles will be available during
the event including warzone's own urban
legend dr karloff
while you're running around in costume
you can participate in the trick or
treat event
it's a scavenger hunt that places 16
specially marked trick-or-treat supply
boxes around the map
find all 16 before the haunting of
verdansk ends and you'll learn yourself
the pumpkin punisher legendary assault
rifle blueprint
it wouldn't be a call of duty halloween
without zombies and you can hang out
with the undead in the new zombie royal
mode
instead of being sent to the gulag when
you die you'll instead respawn as a
zombie
zombies can't use weapons but they can
run and jump better than the living
and they have deadly melee attacks and
thermal vision too
kill two players and collect their
dropped syringes to return as a human
once again
as mentioned before all of this plays
out in the long-awaited nighttime
version of verdansk so no matter what
mode you're playing
prepare for a much darker look as for
regular multiplayer we're getting two
new modes and more
on slaughter sees squads fighting over a
juggernaut suit
while snipers only features snipers only
additionally the capture points and
domination are scarecrows instead of
flags
and the dog tags and kill confirmed have
been turned into skulls
finally no matter what mode you're
playing you can turn your operator's
head into a jack-o-lantern by getting
three kills in a single life
we'll be checking out all the halloween
action on gamespot so swing by to see
all the spooky sights
the haunting of her dance wraps up on
november 3rd and get ready for the next
call of duty not long after that
black ops cold war is out on november
[Music]
13th
you